la noticia de la muerte de la reina
Isabel segunda se conoce en Brasil en
plena campaña electoral y un día después
de la celebraciones del Bicentenario de
la independencia de este país de hecho
antes de morir la Reina Isabel le
felicitó el gobierno brasileño por esa
fecha y el gobierno brasileño acaba de
decretar tres días de luto oficial para
recordar la importancia histórica de la
reina que dice todo solo una vez en su
vida Brasil fue En 1968 en aquella
ocasión se reunió incluso con el rey del
fútbol con Pelé y hoy los periódicos de
Brasil ha recordado ese encuentro
mostrando esa foto histórica otros
políticos Además del propio presidente
Yair bolsonaro han recordado la
importancia de la reina para la historia
contemporánea incluido el ex presidente
Luis Ignacio luna de